Who are some of America's presidents from history?
Let's start with the very first president, George Washington.
He helped start the USA with his friends over two hundred years ago.
He wore a wig and had wooden teeth.
And he was not nice to his cherry tree but at least he told the truth about it.
Sorry.
Abraham Lincoln was the 16th president of the United States.
He was the tallest president ever and not just because he wore such a big hat.
Here's an awesome fact about Abraham Lincoln.
He was a wrestler.
Maybe that's how he won the election.
I wonder if he had a cool wrestling nickname like "The Rock".
The Lincolnator!
Awesome fact number 2.
Lincoln logs are named after him because he was born in a log cabin.
He was really smart and he kept the country together,...
...which I really appreciate.
Another president who had a toy named after him is Teddy Roosevelt,....
...our 26th president.
The Roosevelt bear?
Oh wait, the teddy bear.
That's kind of cool I'd like a bear named after me, too.
He didn't actually have any bears in the White House.
But Calvin Coolidge had a pet hippopotamus.
And Herbert Hoover had pet alligators.
Some presidents had cool hobbies.
Teddy Roosevelt liked to walk around on stilts.
Maybe he wanted to be taller than Abraham Lincoln.
The 44th president Barack Obama collects comic books.
His favorites are Conan the Barbarian and Spiderman.